boxes boxes and more boxes containing
100,000 signatures for opposition
presidential hopeful Barce nadesan
according to a survey conducted by his
own team he has 10% of voter support
that would put him in a second place
after current President Vladimir Putin
main idea of my campaign is to stop the
politics of Mr Putin including the
special military operation the thing is
for the quarter of century Putin has
destroyed the key institutions of
Russian State like Parliament like
courts like free election by the way and
I have to establish again these
institutions a university professor of
physics and a lawyer Baris nadesan has
been engaged in Russian politics for
almost 30 years he was criticized in the
past for cooperating with proog
government parties and the Kremlin he
admits he doesn't have the Charisma of
the murdered politician Boris neov or
the speaking skills of the jailed
opposition activist Alexa navali but
that has not stopped him gaining some
support hundreds of thousands of people
across Russia brav the called and cued
day and night to leave their signature
in favor of his presidential
nomination for me it's important to give
my vote to a candidate who's against the
military operation in
Ukraine this is the only chance to GA
legally and not be detained we're here
not to express protest but just to show
our position now it's a rare chance to
say that we are together and that there
are quite a lot of
us I want to be an active Citizen and I
hope things change for the better in our
country so I decided to take part in
this Julia naal the wife of imprisoned
opposition leader Alexa naal signed for
nadin's nomination but there are many
who predict that the Kremlin could stop
nadan from
running it is clear that if nadesan is
allowed into the presidential race his
rating will increase and this does not
contribute to the unconditional victory
of Putin it seems that denying him
registration now would be more
beneficial for Putin's campaign Nan says
no ma he's allowed to run his team have
already achieved one of their
goals I have thousands of thousands of
posts from people all over the Russia
and they write something like this
I was sure I was alone but I am not
alone a lot of people think like me
moris nadesan is optimistic his name
will appear on the ballot the central
Election Commission has taken time to
verify the submitted signatures and will
announce his decision on whether to
allow nadesan to become a presidential
candidate that ruling is expected in
about a week Julia
shaval
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
Channel get the latest news from Al
jazer